yeah my parents always thought there was
something wrong with me as even as a
baby and what's wrong with this one I
mean you see little you know man you
know I mean and he did the [__]
handicap hand yes yeah I mean the Asian
mom the Asian parents are savages
they're Savages yeah and
um because I had 28 first cousins and
they all got straight A's and I and I
didn't speak English until I was like
14. that's how dumb I was I was just
like you know me eating boogers and like
picking skin off my feet you still eat
boogers I know okay come on relax I'm
single I wanna yeah man I don't want
that out there but my point is is that
you know I there was always something
wrong
but you know I never felt like there was
something wrong I felt like oh I'm
living a normal human experience but I
could see the world reacting with some
of my behaviors and the way I was and
then it always made me feel like is
there something wrong with me but there
isn't you're just a special person yes I
think like we just didn't uh hit our
Prime when we were in college or like a
middle school or like earlier oh see you
think you blossomed late in life I think
yeah you too when you were 14 you just
like you become Bobby Lee you know yeah
yeah how has other Asians treated you in
comedy uh
I don't want to say that but no no
shitty like [__] all other Asians treat
you like [__] yeah it's just the there's
not so many Asians there and they're
like when you are just like uh you are
crazy people don't like crazy people
which I mean I'm crazy because I just uh
by the club and then I just I'm a
workaholic I have to I I want to leave
my husband and I want to have money so I
can take the kids with me
but if you are poor you know you're not
gonna get the kids you know and then
they will never remember you yeah
because if you don't pay for their
school you are not there because you are
you are poor you just you can't be there
for them yeah this life is hard it's so
hard it's really it's toxic money is not
everything but it is not receive like
child support like he's Chinese in China
and he knows everybody uh in China and I
go to court and I'm a lose I'll lose and
I don't really want to live my career I
don't have one yet but I have one soon
uh here from here
and I I rarely say this and and I'm
going with my like John Singleton I'm
going with my instinct right my instinct
is You're Gonna Be a Millionaire
you don't worry it's gonna happen all
right because even with a guy like me
because I'm very like
it takes a lot for me to like you know
um pay attention to somebody especially
in comedy right it sometimes it takes me
10 years to know who somebody's name is
you know and you know they have to hang
around for a while for me to respect
them but with you I've always remembered
you because you have no fear of you used
to even I didn't even know you would say
hi to me
yeah no I I you never know everybody say
hi to you
no I know but these are people that
already know yeah yeah but I didn't even
was really introduced to you and you say
hi to me yes nobody introduced us I just
walked with you yeah you just walked up
to me what you made that eye and made me
scared why why'd you do that I don't do
that yeah and I was thinking like what
Bobby said to me is from a Korean to a
Chinese that's real because I know
you're not seeing it because you won't
be nice because from a Korean Korean and
Chinese we are is is people we don't
like each other but we don't hate each
other either
content but I don't like him we don't
hate each other yeah yeah I don't hate
you either yeah just Japanese is over
there for the option for us the Chinese
and Koreans is like it's like really
like a a very nuanced relationship yeah
it's very new we have we share the same
struggles and then Korea become really
successful like before China got very
rich Korea got very rich After Japan
Korea became very powerful but like now
the Korean culture is very powerful
right now the Korean culture because
there's something about your country you
can do art so your movies you're artists
yeah your movies and your uh like like a
pop culture is not compromised because
in China it's compromised that's right
the government because the government
gets it there is a good art was in Hong
Kong but not anymore right so like it's
a serious thing yeah it's leading in
culture in great arts for Asians like
the movies the best movies are Korean
movies they don't like them but they are
good I know you can't lie about it I
know but when you look at you go oh
because you I always ask myself when I
see a [__] up Korean movie I go they
would never be able to make that here in
America there's this new kdrama I'm
watching called Glory yeah it's so good
like the the pretty Korean girl I think
I think I think that's her it's about
like her she's taking revenge on her
bullies yes yeah pretty easy watching it
John now I'm gonna start to watch it
that's good you know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna do maybe a couple times a year
I want to do an Asian review stand-up
show in LA
that's amazing right and it's going to
be the people I like
and you're going to be on it and it's
going to be great because this this new
crop of kids that are coming up because
back then I really back in my day it was
like oh that guy's not funny I got you
know I mean but now I'm seeing like real
[__] funny people that make me laugh
and go oh my God like Peter Kim that you
know I mean the winter Kim is so funny
the Whimsical you know I mean like he's
so Whimsical and gay yeah I mean and
like you know butthole loose fine that's
his thing you know hot husband hot
husband yeah yeah that dude right is is
so intimidating in terms of Comedy I
look at him and I go [__] this guy has
way more skill set than I do I mean look
at Jo koy's rise I mean he's just I mean
it's you know watching Ali you know all
these people rise and I just think that
we should it's time that we do I think a
a consistent show doing anything in La
showcase the Asian American comedian
yeah but really cool ones though yeah
cool ones you know what I learned about
um China recently is that the
Chinese
woman oh yeah and then she rose up and
became had a bigger Fleet of people than
even bigger than Blackbeard
I forgot like what's